Let's now talk about scheduling and fairness. And then
we talked about, in a crossbar switch, the process
of matching input ports to output ports. The decision
about which ports should be matched in any particular
time slot is a process called scheduling. There are
two important goals in scheduling. One is efficiency which
is to say that if there is traffic at
inputs distant for output ports, the crossbar switch should schedule
inputs and outputs. So that traffic isn't sitting
idle at the input ports if some traffic could
be sent to the available output ports. Another
consideration in scheduling is fairness, which is to say
that given demands at the inputs, we want
to make sure that each queue at the input
is scheduled fairly for some definition of fairness. Now,
defining fairness is tricky. And there are multiple possible
definitions of fairness. Here, we'll look at
an important fairness definition called max min fairness.